it is mind-blowing to me the amount of
songs you wrote that became you know big
hits big number one hits and it's also
mind-blowing to me that you were that
generous with them like you'd give them
to the temptations and you would give
them to other bands
you didn't care
everybody why would you do that when you
hear i'll use my girl for instance my
girl has become
as a songwriter my international anthem
that's right i play places howard where
the basic language is not even english
all over the world and people you know
my girl absolutely as soon as they get
phone phone phone phone but they know
what's going to happen you know
absolutely so
but
people say well aren't you aren't you
sorry you didn't keep that for yourself
you get into temptations no because word
not for the temptations i probably never
would have written my girl
you wrote it in two hours did you hear
that bassline first did you do yeah i
just heard that and that's how i wanted
the song to start however
the guitar riff which has come one of
the most has become one of the most
famous guitar riffs
in the in musical history i guess uh
there was a in the funk brothers the
league guitarist was a guy named robert
white
so we're doing the session the basic the
session for my girl the first time and
james jameson who was our base player i
said okay i want you to play boom boom
boom boom
so we're just running it down you know
we haven't even started recording it and
robert stands up in the studio and
starts playing boom boom boom boom boom
this is called ooh baby baby this song
was an accident describe that accident
if you don't mind
uh back in the day the miracles and i
used to sing a a medley of love songs uh
towards the end of our concerts and of
love songs that were popular by other
groups at that time and there were about
five songs in that medley one night we
were in at the howard theatre in
washington dc and we're singing this
medley of songs when we got to the end
of it rather than ending it and the
miracles and i was so in tune to each
other the guys would just fall into
whatever i did so i just started saying
ooh baby baby
and they started singing harmonizing
with it the crowd went crazy so we said
okay we'll put that in every night so we
put that in and then we said hey we
might as well make a record like that
and we did and how does that process go
after you do the you baby baby the
crowds like that that little riff
you go home you think about that and
then you create a lyric and and you
create a uh
song
and then the process works differently
sometimes too like for example on the
tracks of my tears you didn't write the
music but the guy who wrote the music
couldn't figure out the lyrics right so
he comes to you right yeah and he says
hey smokey i got a great little track
here he was my guitars right yeah and he
used to put his guitar riffs on tape for
me and give them to me
hard to write the lyrics to
this um
yeah
it was why just took me a while to come
up with something that i felt was
different uh the first part of the
the song for this song that i ever wrote
was take a good look at my face see my
smile looks out of place if you look
closer it's easier to trace that you're
gone no that's not it you see the trace
that i still love you don't love me no
that's not it i went through several of
those you know one morning howard i'm
shaving and i'm looking at my face in
the mirror and i'm saying gosh what if a
person had cried so much until if you
look closely at their face you can see
tracks that their tears have made and i
said that's it wow so
and the rest of the song fell into place
after that